we do have some good vibes for you
courtesy of kevin bacon who shares the
same birthday as me this friday july 8th
put in your calendar that's your one
degree of kevin bacon that is do you
have you share the same bread everyone's
got a six degrees you got the one that's
true yeah okay and his daughter so see
bacon okay in a new video shared to
instagram kevin shared a clip of him his
wife kira sedgwick and associates
singing taylor swift and chris
stapleton's track i bet you think about
me alongside their farm animals of
course come on there's got to be like a
super cute clip and you're very talented
i want to be a part of this family buy
one
now that we're done and it's over
i bet you couldn't believe
when you realize
when you're out at your cool indie music
concerts
every week i bet you think about me
in your house with your organic shoes in
your billion-dollar couch
i'll let you think about me
when you say oh my god she's insane she
wrote a song about me
[Music]
i bet you think about me